There's a scene in the film I Am Legend where, OK, civilization is over. The only person left alive in New York is Will Smith, and he is not able to find traces of anyone else alive anywhere on Earth. And every morning, he wakes up and makes himself breakfast, and puts on videos of The Today Show from back before the Earth was destroyed just to make the morning seem normal.
电影《我是传奇》中有一幕，文明已经终结。纽约唯一幸存的人是威尔·史密斯，他无法在地球上找到任何其他生还者的踪迹。每天早上，他起床为自己做早餐，播放地球毁灭前的《今日秀》录像，只是为了让早晨看起来正常一点。
One of the sports fans on our staff, Matt, was saying the other day that that is exactly what it's like today, watching the constant replays of old sports on television. He's watched the 2018 Stanley Cup, the NBA Finals Game 7 from 2013, an old Yankees game from 1978, the Masters last year that Tiger Woods won, all that glory from back when life was normal and sports was part of it. Part of the thrill of the Michael Jordan documentary The Last Dance was it wasn't just sports, but a primetime Sunday night sports event that you could look forward to and you could watch, knowing other fans were watching and talk about, and share memes just like the world used to be.
我们的一位体育迷同事马特前几天说，现在的情况正是这样，电视上不断重播着旧体育赛事。他看了2018年斯坦利杯、2013年NBA总决赛第七场、1978年洋基队的一场旧比赛，还有去年泰格·伍兹赢得的大师赛，这一切都重现了生活正常、体育作为其中一部分时的荣耀。迈克尔·乔丹的纪录片《最后之舞》之所以激动人心，是因为它不仅仅是体育，而是一场周日黄金时段的体育盛事，你可以对此充满期待，并一边观看一边与同样在观看的朋友谈论、分享表情包，就像世界过去的样子。
These two guys who write about college football, Jason Kirk and Spencer Hall, wrote this thing that I love about the lack of sports in our world today. These are guys who normally spend over 50 hours a week on a slow week watching games and thinking about sports, who these days, like hungry men raiding an empty kitchen pantry for any scrap of food, have resorted to watching old college games that they've seen before and live Korean baseball in the middle of the night, and the German soccer league, Bundesliga.
这两位撰写大学橄榄球文章的人，杰森·柯克和斯宾塞·霍尔，写了一篇我非常喜欢的文章，关于当今世界上体育赛事的缺失。这些人通常每周花超过50个小时（在比赛少的周）观看比赛并思考体育，而如今，他们就像在空荡荡的储藏室里搜寻食物碎屑的饥饿者，不得不转而观看以前看过的旧大学比赛，以及半夜直播的韩国棒球和德国足球甲级联赛。
Saturday morning, the choice was between Bundesliga and cornhole, the American tailgate game where people throw sandbags at a wooden plank.
周六早上，选择是在德甲联赛和玉米洞游戏之间，这是一种美国人经常在车尾派对上玩的，把沙袋扔向木板的游戏。
That's Jason. Here's Spencer, explaining what he's come to.
那是杰森。这是斯宾塞，他解释了他现在的处境。
I, yesterday, put on for the edification of my kids and their larger education, Ricky Steamboat versus Macho Man Randy Savage at WrestleMania 3. And it's largely considered the greatest wrestling match of all time. And I realized that since I'm homeschooling my kids, they had to see the important classics of my culture.
昨天，为了熏陶我的孩子们并让他们接受更广泛的教育，我给他们播放了《摔角狂热3》中瑞奇·斯廷博特对阵“野蛮人”兰迪·萨维奇的比赛。这被广泛认为是史上最伟大的摔角比赛。我意识到，既然我在家教我的孩子们，他们就必须看到我这一代文化中重要的经典。
The canon.
正典。
The canon, yeah. No, I mean, it really-- we're joking, but we're not. Like canonically, there's a lot of controversy about what is in the canon, wrestling-wise. No one disputes this.
正典，没错。不，我是说，这真的……我们在开玩笑，但也不是。就像在正典里一样，关于摔角方面的内容有很多争议。这一点没人有异议。
Spencer's watching way fewer games under lockdown, and sometimes he says he thought this actually might be better for him, in some way, to devote fewer hours to sports, maybe.
斯宾塞在封锁期间观看的比赛少多了，有时他说他觉得这在某种程度上对他更好，也许应该把更少的时间投入到体育上。
Maybe. But it also makes me realize that the things I fill them with aren't much better. There's a lot of empty--
也许吧。但这也让我意识到，我用来填补它们的东西也好不到哪儿去。那里有很多空虚——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There's a lot of empty space out there, man. There's a lot of empty space in life. And when somebody says, well, now you can fill it with something really meaningful, will you? Or is that even an option?
那里有很多空虚，伙计。生活中有很多空白。当有人说，好吧，现在你可以用更有意义的东西来填补它，你会吗？或者那甚至是一个选择吗？
I think there's only so much meaning you can pack into the hours of a week. I think there's only so much productivity within one person. I think that's something, by the way, this has forced me to confront.
我觉得你一周的时间里能塞入的意义是有限的。我认为一个人能拥有的生产力是有限的。顺便说一句，我认为这是这件事迫使我面对的事情。
Anyway, the essay these guys wrote about sports during these sportsless months is called "What Were Sports?" And the tone of it is like people who live in tents surrounded by rubble after a war, remembering what it was like to live in houses, looking back on their old lives, which only now they appreciate for what they were. The essay starts this way.
总之，这些人在这几个月没有体育的日子里写的关于体育的文章叫《体育曾是什么？》。它的语调就像战争结束后住在瓦砾堆中帐篷里的人们，回忆起住在房子里的感觉，回首他们过去的生活，直到现在他们才意识到那些生活意味着什么。这篇文章是这样开始的。
I remember there were expensive commercials. I definitely remember expensive commercials being a part of live sports. I only noticed this when sports on replay happened. The ads for replay games are cheap and very sad-- home generators, car warranties, bootleg tactical gear for things that shouldn't be tactical, like car visors and hearing aids.
我记得以前有很多昂贵的广告。我确实记得昂贵的广告是现场体育比赛的一部分。我只有在重播体育赛事时才注意到这一点。重播比赛的广告很廉价，而且非常悲哀——家庭发电机、汽车保修、不该用于战术目的的东西的盗版战术装备，比如汽车遮阳板和助听器。
Do you remember how, back when there were sports, each person had a list of teams they strongly preferred to win? Like if the Portland Trail Blazers and Memphis Grizzlies squared off, you and I would be a little bit happier about life if the Grizzlies were the team that won. What was that all about?
你还记得以前有体育比赛的时候，每个人都有一份他们强烈希望获胜的球队名单吗？比如如果波特兰开拓者队和孟菲斯灰熊队对垒，如果灰熊队赢了，你和我会对生活感到更快乐一点。那到底是怎么回事？
Other things they miss-- Phillies fans doing things that were not normal for anybody but Phillies fans; spreadsheets of sports statistics for each game, whose results then went into a spreadsheet for the whole season, which then went into a historical archives spreadsheet. "Watching a four-hour game and walking away with one GIF-worthy moment," they write, "felt like a version of sifting for gold, but a version in which the dirt itself was valuable."
他们怀念的其他事情——费城人队的球迷做着除了费城人球迷外对任何人来说都不正常的事情；每一场比赛的体育统计数据电子表格，其结果随后进入整个赛季的电子表格，然后进入历史档案电子表格。“看完一场四个小时的比赛，只带走一个值得制作成GIF的时刻，”他们写道，“感觉就像是淘金，但在这个版本中，泥土本身就是有价值的。”
One cool thing I remember about sports is watching people run fast in one direction. It was fun to watch someone do this when unimpeded, such as when Usain Bolt walked into a mall in church shoes or whatever and ran as fast as the fastest NFL player ever had. But it was 10 times as fun when someone was able to run really far while other people were trying to stop that person from running far.
我记得关于体育的一件很酷的事情是看着人们朝一个方向快速奔跑。当无人阻挡时看人这样做很有趣，比如当尤塞恩·博尔特穿着教堂鞋走进商场之类的，跑得和有史以来最快的NFL球员一样快。但当有人试图在其他人试图阻止那个人跑远时还能跑得很远，那就要有趣十倍了。
Also fun, watching big people try to stop fast people from running. They write, "Sports were little chemistry labs designed to run for hours, months, and centuries, along the way producing countless things nobody could have predicted from the onset-- a cool, otherworldly space place where people could completely depressurize for several hours and sometimes succumb to space madness along the way when things went haywire."
同样有趣的是，看着大个子试图阻止快手奔跑。他们写道，“体育是设计用来运行数小时、数月和数世纪的小型化学实验室，在此过程中产生无数从一开始就无法预测的事情——一个很酷的、超凡脱俗的空间，人们可以在那里完全减压几个小时，有时在此过程中当事情失控时会陷入太空疯狂。”
Do you remember that part? That part was like Apollo 13. Like when your team's starting safety went out with an injury and they had to figure out how to play with 10 defenders and one guy who should have been going to law school instead of covering the other team's best receiver. That part was a problem, but a fun one to solve.
你还记得那部分吗？那部分就像阿波罗13号。就像当你的球队的首发安全卫因伤下场，他们不得不设法用10名防守队员，以及一个本该去读法学院而不是去盯防对方最佳接球手的家伙来比赛。那部分是个问题，但却是一个解决起来很有趣的问题。
These problems very much belong to someone else, despite us getting to invest feelings in whether they solved these problems or not. Caring about whether a mediocre general manager could finally figure out how to do sports budgets, this was kind of like politics, but in a fake world in which we didn't have to acknowledge politics can kill us. That was nice.
这些问题很大程度上属于别人，尽管我们有机会投入感情去关注他们是否解决了这些问题。关心一个平庸的总经理是否能最终弄清楚如何制定体育预算，这有点像政治，但在一个虚构的世界里，我们不必承认政治可能会杀死我们。那感觉真好。
There's a whole passage in the essay where Spencer reminisces about the last live game he went to, LSU and Clemson in New Orleans, and got oysters before the game, and met a friend at a restaurant the next day to eat and talk football for hours. He writes, "Do you hear all the beats of an impossible world playing there? I do. I feel every little ping of a world that I've only missed for 45 days at this point, like cactus needles just pressing into the skin of a hovering hand." Jason sums it all up neatly with this.
文章中有一整段话是斯宾塞回忆他参加的最后一场现场比赛，在纽奥良的LSU和克莱姆森队的比赛，赛前吃了牡蛎，第二天在餐厅遇到朋友吃饭聊了几个小时的橄榄球。他写道，“你听到那里演奏的一个不可能的世界的所有节拍了吗？我听到了。我感受到一个我目前只错过了45天的世界的每一次微小的悸动，就像仙人掌针刺入悬浮在空中的手掌皮肤。”杰森用这个简洁地总结了一切。
For me, the thing that mattered most about sports is how they, by design, did not matter. We built industrial complexes around them, but at heart they were about discovering which side had earned the right to shout the cooler obscenities on any given day. And then the following day, we would rediscover.
对我来说，体育最重要的事情是它们在设计上是如何无关紧要的。我们围绕它们建立了工业综合体，但从本质上讲，它们是为了发现哪一方在任何特定的一天赢得了大声喊出更酷的粗话的权利。然后第二天，我们会重新发现。
Well, today on our program, for everybody who is yearning for sports right now in our sportsless world, we try to help with radio methadone for your sports addiction. Is that metaphor too negative? We have sports stories from back before the lockdown, back when professional sports were still a vital daily living force. We relive the thrill of victory and the agony of defeat.
嗯，今天在我们的节目中，对于现在在这个没有体育的世界里渴望体育的每个人，我们尝试用“体育成瘾的广播美沙酮”来提供帮助。那个比喻是不是太负面了？我们有来自封锁前的体育故事，那时职业体育仍然是一种重要的日常力量。我们重温胜利的快感和失败的痛苦。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请留下来。
Act One, Friday Night Floodlights. OK, so let's begin with this story of people yearning for sports to begin again in a moment a few years back, when nothing was normal at all. Businesses were shut down. School was canceled. Kids were stuck home. This story happened right after Hurricane Katrina, in two towns in Mississippi that sit right on the Gulf of Mexico, Waveland and Bay St. Louis.
第一幕，周五晚上的泛光灯。好吧，让我们从这个故事开始，关于几年前人们渴望体育重新开始的时刻，那时什么都不正常。企业倒闭了。学校停课了。孩子们被困在家里。这个故事发生在卡特里娜飓风之后，在密西西比州位于墨西哥湾沿岸的两个城镇，韦弗兰和圣路易斯湾。
Waveland was pretty much wiped out in the hurricane. Most homes and businesses there were destroyed or severely damaged. Bay St. Louis only did a little better.
韦弗兰在飓风中几乎被摧毁了。那里的大多数房屋和企业被毁坏或严重损坏。圣路易斯湾的情况稍好一点。
A month after the hurricane, when we broadcast our story about them, most people still didn't have electricity. You couldn't drink water from the faucet. One of the first things they decided to bring back, even before that other stuff-- football, high school football. One of our producers back then, Lisa Pollak, went down there in 2005 during those early weeks after Katrina and put together this story.
飓风过后一个月，当我们播出关于他们的故事时，大多数人仍然没有电。你不能喝水龙头里的水。他们决定的第一件要带回来的事情，甚至在那之前——橄榄球，高中橄榄球。我们当时的一位制片人丽莎·波拉克在2005年卡特里娜飓风后的最初几周去了那里，并将这个故事组合在一起。
The Bay High Tigers played their first game of the season on the Friday before Katrina. They beat Hancock High, 30-14. After the storm, the joke was that they'd gone undefeated. Everyone figured the season was over. Players were homeless. The high school was closed.
湾区高中老虎队在卡特里娜飓风前的周五打了他们赛季的第一场比赛。他们以30比14击败了汉考克高中。风暴过后，人们开玩笑说他们保持不败。每个人都认为赛季结束了。球员们无家可归。高中也关闭了。
But just days after the hurricane, the Bay High coach, Brenan Compretta, started hearing from his players. They wanted to play football. They called his cell and sent text messages. They stopped him on the street. They wanted to play football. They wanted something that reminded them of what life was before.
但在飓风发生后的几天里，湾区高中的教练布雷南·康普雷塔开始收到他球员的消息。他们想打橄榄球。他们打他的手机，发短信。他们在街上拦住他。他们想打橄榄球。他们想要一些能让他们想起以前生活的东西。
The thing that a lot of them were saying is it only takes 11 to play, and that no matter how many they had, they wanted to do this. That was the only thing that they had to look forward to.
他们很多人都在说的是，只需要11个人就能比赛，无论他们有多少人，他们都想做这件事。那是他们唯一可以期待的事情。
You wouldn't stage a school play without a school, but football's different-- here, anyway. In Bay St. Louis, game day starts at 6:30 AM with a team breakfast at a church. Newspaper stories about the game are posted on the wall at school. In the afternoon, drummers from the band march through the hallways just before the pep rally. Strangers in town stop players to talk about that week's game.
你不会在没有学校的情况下排演一部校园剧，但橄榄球不同——至少在这里是这样。在圣路易斯湾，比赛日从早上6点30分的教堂团队早餐开始。关于比赛的报纸文章张贴在学校的墙上。下午，乐队的鼓手在激励大会前走过走廊。镇上的陌生人拦住球员谈论当周的比赛。
So even though school won't start again until November, the coach called a meeting to try to restart the team. There were some challenges. Only 19 players showed up of the 70 who are on the team. They couldn't use their practice field since National Guardsmen were camping there. Their field house was destroyed and most of their equipment. And as for their uniforms--
所以尽管学校要到11月才重新开学，教练还是召集了一次会议试图重启球队。有一些挑战。在球队的70名球员中只有19人到场。他们无法使用他们的练习场，因为国民警卫队在那里露营。他们的更衣室被毁了，大部分装备也是。至于他们的队服——
We pulled up a few days after the storm. They had people running around in our jerseys and cleats, and throwing balls around. And I guess it was fathers and sons or whatever.
我们在风暴过后几天开车过去。他们有人穿着我们的球衣和球鞋跑来跑去，还在扔球。我想那是父亲和儿子之类的。
Wait, you saw people wearing your guys' football jerseys just as, like, replacement clothes?
等等，你看到有人穿着你们队员的橄榄球球衣，就像是作为替换衣服？
Right, exactly. And considering the circumstances, I didn't get really upset about it. I just was like, well, I guess if they need some clothes, they can go ahead and take them.
对，完全正确。考虑到当时的情况，我并没有真正感到难过。我只是想，好吧，我想如果他们需要一些衣服，他们可以继续拿走。
They're saying that there's a possibility-- they're saying it's probably going to be one of the most packed games we've played ever.
他们说有一种可能性——他们说这可能是我们打过的最拥挤的比赛之一。
It's game day, the Tigers' very first game since Hurricane Katrina, one month after the storm. And I had flown to Mississippi, where Tyler Brush, the team's quarterback, is showing me around. There's not a lot to see, just huge piles of wreckage, and near the beach, mile after mile of empty spaces where houses and buildings used to be.
今天是比赛日，老虎队自卡特里娜飓风以来的第一场比赛，风暴发生一个月后。我飞到了密西西比州，球队的四分卫泰勒·布拉什正在带我参观。没什么可看的，只有巨大的残骸堆，在海滩附近，一英里又一英里曾经是房屋和建筑的地方现在空空如也。
After the hurricane, Tyler's family left for a while, moved to Florida, to a town where they used to live. They got a nice house, and Tyler began high school there. He was practicing with their football squad, and he was going to be a starter there too. But then Coach Compretta called. Tyler says coming back here was a hard choice.
飓风过后，泰勒一家离开了一段时间，搬到了佛罗里达，搬到了他们以前住的一个城镇。他们有了一栋漂亮的房子，泰勒开始在那里上高中。他在那里和他们的橄榄球队一起训练，他也将成为那里的首发。但后来康普雷塔教练打了电话。泰勒说回到这里是一个艰难的选择。
My dad, he originally didn't want me to come back. I mean, he was pretty much against it, but he decided-- I mean, he said that it was my decision. I mean, I had to think about it a lot.
我爸爸，他最初不想让我回来。我的意思是，他基本上反对它，但他决定——我的意思是，他说这是我的决定。我的意思是，我必须多想想它。
I was nervous about coming back. I mean, I recognized the situation. I knew I was taking a chance if I came back here. College teams might not see me playing. But I felt that I still needed to come back, though, for whoever did come back.
我对回来感到紧张。我的意思是，我认识到了情况。我知道如果我回到这里我是在冒险。大学球队可能看不到我比赛。但我仍然觉得我必须回来，为了那些回来的人。
As quarterback, he didn't want to let the team down. So now his family's living 15 miles away in Diamond Head, and two of the team's other players whose families didn't return are living with them too. This is a strange place to be a kid right now.
作为四分卫，他不想让球队失望。所以现在他的家人住在15英里外的钻石角，球队另外两名家人没有回来的球员也和他们住在一起。这是一个奇怪的地方，作为一个孩子现在在这里。
With no school, they spend their days doing cleanup work, hauling out sheet rock, and moving trees and debris. It's bleak and boring. Their favorite hangouts are gone. Football is one of the few things they have left.
没有学校，他们整天做清理工作，搬运石膏板，搬运树木和碎片。这很凄凉和无聊。他们最喜欢的聚会地点都不见了。橄榄球是他们仅存的几样东西之一。
We're actually pulling up to my house now. Yeah, this is-- pretty much nothing left of my house. There's stairs right here-- were right here, leading up to the house. They're completely gone.
我们实际上正开车去我家。是的，这是——我家几乎什么都没剩下。这里有楼梯——刚才就在这儿，通向房子的楼梯。它们完全不见了。
Literally all we are looking at are the wooden stilts that held up the house and the foundation, which looks like it was lifted up from the ground.
我们看到的字面上只是支撑房子的木柱和地基，看起来像是从地上被抬起来一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And I mean, there isn't even stuff around, like furniture, or clothes. Where did all the stuff go?
我的意思是，周围甚至没有东西，比如家具或衣服。所有东西都去哪儿了？
I guess the water just washed them up that way-- wiped out. There's nothing left.
我猜水只是把它们冲走了——冲没了。什么都没剩下。
Does anybody in here need pants? You need pants, come with me.
这里有人需要裤子吗？你需要裤子，跟我来。
Over at the football field, the new uniforms arrive just in time, a gift from a man in North Carolina. And the kids line up while the coaches open the boxes.
在橄榄球场，新队服及时到达，是一个北卡罗来纳州的人送的礼物。当教练打开盒子时，孩子们排起了队。
2, 3, 4, 5.
2, 3, 4, 5。
The new jerseys are blue and white, not blue and gold, the school colors, but no one seems to care.
新球衣是蓝色和白色的，不是蓝色和金色的学校颜色，但没人介意。
Hold on. Hey, man. We're not getting picky here. Just relax, buddy. What do you need?
等一下。嘿，伙计。我们不是要挑剔。放松点，伙计。你需要什么？
This isn't the team it used to be. Over half the Tigers still haven't come back, so the coaches have filled out the roster with some new recruits-- a few seniors who've never played football, some freshmen from the school's ninth grade team, two guys from the Tigers' archrival, St. Stanislaus-- they canceled their season-- and to cap it all off Bad News Bears style, some scared looking seventh and eighth graders from the junior high. In all, it's still just 29 players, a long way from 70.
这不是以前的那个球队了。超过一半的老虎队球员还没回来，所以教练组用一些新招募的球员填补了名单——几个从未打过橄榄球的高年级学生，一些来自学校九年级球队的一年级新生，两个来自老虎队死敌圣斯塔尼斯拉夫高中的家伙——他们取消了赛季——最后，用“坏消息熊”风格，一些看起来很害怕的初中七、八年级学生。总而言之，仍然只有29名球员，离70人还差得远。
Some of these kids are all but homeless, sleeping on other families' couches and floors. One linebacker is living in a camper alone, his parents hours away, all so he can play football. With everything these kids have been dealing with and everything they've seen, they seem genuinely relieved and excited to be here today, putting on jerseys and lacing up cleats.
其中一些孩子几乎无家可归，睡在其他家庭的沙发和地板上。一名线卫独自住在一辆露营车里，他的父母在几小时路程外，这一切只是为了让他能打橄榄球。面对这些孩子一直以来所处理的一切以及他们所看到的一切，他们今天看起来确实松了一口气，并为能在这里穿上球衣和系上球鞋感到兴奋。
Everybody's just anxious to play again, to get things back to normal.
每个人都只是急于再次比赛，让事情恢复正常。
That's Trevor Adam, a senior tight end. And for him, getting things back to normal means pretty much one thing.
那是特雷弗·亚当，一名高年级近端锋。对他来说，让事情恢复正常基本上意味着一件事。
I love hitting people. I mean, there is no better feeling in the world just unloading on somebody. I mean, even now, dealing with all this, you have an extra feel of warmth. You get just that exciting feeling about hitting somebody. There's no-- you can't explain it.
我喜欢撞人。我的意思是，世界上没有比撞倒某人更好的感觉了。我的意思是，即使现在，处理这一切，你有一种额外的温暖感。你只是得到了那种撞击某人的兴奋感。没有——你无法解释它。
Equally excited is Brandt, a tenth grader. I think Brandt might be one of the happiest kids I've ever met. He doesn't stop beaming, even when he's talking about swimming through his flooded kitchen or living for weeks without plumbing or power. He moved to Texas to stay with a relative for a while, but didn't stay long.
同样兴奋的是布兰特，一名十年级学生。我觉得布兰特可能是我见过的最快乐的孩子之一。他不停地笑着，即使在他谈论游泳穿过他被淹没的厨房或者在没有管道或电力的情况下生活了数周时也是如此。他搬到得克萨斯州和亲戚住了一段时间，但没待多久。
Texas was great. Everybody was real kind, like scary kind. It was just like-- have you ever seen The Stepford Wives, how everything's perfect? That's how it was. They were all like, hi, how are you doing? Oh, can I get you anything-- clothes, food? And I'm like, I'm fine, ma'am.
得克萨斯州很棒。每个人都很友善，就像可怕的友善。就像——你看过《复制娇妻》吗，一切是如何完美的？那就是那样。他们都像，嗨，你好吗？噢，我能为你拿点什么——衣服，食物？然后我就像，我很好，女士。
Does this feel like a normal couple hours before a game, or does it feel different?
这感觉像赛前几个小时的正常状态吗，还是感觉不同？
Way different.
非常不同。
One thing I'm going to miss before the games, the pregame meals. And we don't have that here.
我比赛前会想念的一件事是赛前餐。我们这里没有那个。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Them pregame meals were good, all you can eat.
那赛前餐很好，管饱。
What kind of food?
什么样的食物？
Oh, baked chicken with all these spices on it. It was so good.
噢，上面撒了各种香料的烤鸡。太棒了。
You're making me hungry.
你让我饿了。
That was like a month ago.
那是一个月前的事了。
So you've stayed here this whole time. What's there been to eat for you?
所以你一直待在这里。你吃了什么？
Oh, three meals a day, MREs.
噢，一天三顿饭，MRE（即食口粮）。
So what's an MRE taste like?
那MRE是什么味道？
I'll tell you what. Meal number 20 and meal number 22-- 20 is spaghetti, and 22 is jambalaya-- the best. I told my mama she should step it up, because that stuff is-- I'm going to start getting MREs just regular.
我告诉你。20号餐和22号餐——20号是意大利面，22号是什锦饭——最棒。我告诉妈妈她应该改进一下，因为那些东西是——我开始要把MRE当成常规饮食了。
All right. Hey, guys. Everybody right here where these guys are. Get down. Y'all can take a knee or something. Let's go, real quick. You can sit down or take a knee, either one.
好的。嘿，伙计们。每个人都在这些人所在的地方。蹲下。你们可以跪着或什么的。走吧，快点。你们可以坐下或跪着，都可以。
It's late afternoon now, about an hour before the game. Everybody gathers around Coach Compretta, and he urges them to think about the past month when they get on the field tonight.
现在是傍晚晚些时候，离比赛还有一个小时。每个人都聚集在康普雷塔教练周围，他敦促他们今晚在球场上时想想过去的一个月。
Everything you have inside of you, let it out. All the aggravation, the frustration, having to get up and do all the junk you do every day because of this hurricane, let it all out right here. Play for your community, OK? That's why you're here, OK?
你内心的一切，把它释放出来。所有的烦恼，挫折，因为这场飓风每天必须起床做所有那些破事，把它全部释放出来就在这里。为你的社区比赛，好吗？这就是你们在这里的原因，好吗？
Some people can't be here. Play for the guys who can't be here too. Play for Bay St. Louis and Waveland. Does anybody have any questions about anything-- offense, defense, special teams block? What?
有些人不能来这里。为那些不能来这里的人比赛。为圣路易斯湾和韦弗兰比赛。关于任何事情有人有问题吗——进攻，防守，特勤组封堵？什么？
I love everybody.
我爱每一个人。
We love you too, Cal.
我们也爱你，卡尔。
Love you too, Cal.
也爱你，卡尔。
Of course, there's only so much love one football team can take. An hour later, as the team gets ready to run out onto the field, the coach has this to say.
当然，一个橄榄球队能承受的爱是有限的。一小时后，当球队准备跑上球场时，教练说了这样的话。
So forget all the kindness and niceness right now, all that junk. Go out there, and get after their behinds. Do you understand me?
所以现在忘记所有的仁慈和友好，所有那些破事。出去，然后追上他们的屁股。你听懂了吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
OK, guys. Now, we do want to win the football game, OK? Everybody touch somebody. Let's go.
好的，伙计们。现在，我们确实想赢下这场橄榄球比赛，好吗？每个人都触碰一下别人。走吧。
Break it down! One time win!
打破它！赢一次！
[SHOUTING AND CHEERING]
[呼喊和欢呼]
Ladies and gentlemen, your Bay High Tigers.
女士们，先生们，你们的湾区老虎队。
It's kind of hard to believe that out of the ruins of this town just down the street from gutted houses and buildings, this thing has appeared, this movie-set-perfect football game. It's dusk now, with a pinkish sky, and under the stadium lights, everything's kind of glowing. And everyone showed up to play their part-- the cheerleaders, the PA announcer, the marching band or what's left of it, a single kid with a snare drum standing in the bleachers.
很难相信在这个小镇的废墟中，在被掏空的房屋和建筑物的街下，出现了这个东西，这个像电影布景一样完美的橄榄球比赛。现在是黄昏，天空呈现粉红色，在体育场的灯光下，一切都在发光。每个人都出场扮演自己的角色——啦啦队，PA播音员，行进乐队或者剩下的部分，一个在看台上拿着小鼓的孩子。
Please join me in singing the national anthem.
请和我一起唱国歌。
The opposing team, the Long Beach Bearcats, line up on the other side of the field. The moment I see them, my heart sinks a little. Not only are there twice as many of them, they just look so determined. Assistant Coach Keith sizes them up this way.
对手球队，长滩野猫队，在球场的另一边排成一列。当我看到他们时，我的心稍微沉了一下。不仅他们的人数是我们的两倍，而且他们看起来是如此坚定。基思助理教练是这样评估他们的。
[LAUGHS] Oh, big. They came here on three buses. We need a minivan. [LAUGHS] Big difference. And they don't have junior kids out there. We do.
[笑] 噢，大个子。他们乘三辆巴士来这里。我们需要一辆小型货车。[笑] 巨大的差异。而且他们没有初中孩子在那里。我们有。
Not even the quarterback's father expects the Tigers to win tonight. They're missing so many guys that they'll have to play their good players twice as much. Their starters will play offense and defense. Guys will wear out.
连四分卫的父亲都不指望老虎队今晚赢球。他们缺席了太多人，他们必须让他们的好球员多打两倍的时间。他们的首发球员将打进攻和防守。球员们会耗尽体力。
Doing the kicking for the Bearcats, Chip Vonderbruegge.
为野猫队踢球的是奇普·冯德布鲁格。
Right there.
就在那儿。
The Tigers get off to a great start. The first time they get the ball, they go on a drive that lasts half the first quarter and ends with a touchdown on a six-yard run by Robert Labat.
老虎队有一个很好的开始。第一次拿到球时，他们进行了持续了第一节一半时间的推进，并以罗伯特·拉巴特的6码冲球得分结束。
Let's go Tigers! Let's go Tigers!
走吧老虎队！走吧老虎队！
I watch Tyler pass the ball off to Robert, knowing that Tyler pretty much moved back to town for this moment, and that Robert-- who's living with him, separated from his own family-- did too.
我看着泰勒把球传给罗伯特，知道泰勒几乎是为了这一刻搬回镇上的，而罗伯特——和他住在一起，与他自己的家人分开——也是如此。
Get out there. Go, go, go.
出去。走，走，走。
Watch your man! Yeah, yeah!
看好你的人！对，对！
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑，跑。
[SHOUTING AND CHEERING]
[呼喊和欢呼]
Watch your play!
看好你的比赛！
Tiger touchdown.
老虎队达阵。
Let's go, D! Let's go, D!
走吧，D！走吧，D！
Tigers on the board.
老虎队得分。
Hey, hey, here we go.
嘿，嘿，我们走吧。
On the sidelines, eight Tiger cheerleaders are jumping around. It's more than half the squad. One tells me her uniform was the first thing she packed when her family evacuated. When the girls aren't cheering, they're consulting this big, elaborate chart they've set up in front of bleachers. Celeste, the captain, explains.
在场边，八名老虎队啦啦队员在跳跃。这超过了全队的一半。一个告诉我，当她家人撤离时，她的制服是她打包的第一件事。当女孩们不欢呼时，她们在查看她们在看台前设置的大型、详尽的图表。队长塞莱斯特解释说。
This is our cheer list, and we have 63 cheers on it. And every year, we just take it and we add more to it.
这是我们的欢呼清单，我们上面有63个欢呼。每年，我们只是拿着它并增加更多。
OK, so like, what's 36?
好的，那么，36是什么？
36 is G-O, go, Tigers, go.
36是G-O，加油，老虎，加油。
And then what's 37?
然后37是什么？
37 is G-O, go, go, G-O, go.
37是G-O，加油，加油，G-O，加油。
And what's 28?
那28是什么？
Go, go, G-O. Go, Tigers, go.
加油，加油，G-O。加油，老虎，加油。
There's some similarity.
有一些相似之处。
Yes, they're very.
是的，非常。
The coaches are scurrying up and down the field, improvising to fill in for the key players they don't have, swapping kids in and out. Brandt, the MRE kid, is getting trounced out there, so the coach pulls him aside.
教练们在场上跑来跑去，即兴发挥以填补他们没有的关键球员，把孩子们换来换去。MRE孩子布兰特在那边被狠狠地教训了一顿，所以教练把他拉到一边。
Hey, Brandt. Not bad, baby. Not bad, baby. Make a change. Put somebody in there with a little more behind on him, OK?
嘿，布兰特。不错，宝贝。不错，宝贝。换人。放一个更有屁股的人进去，好吗？
Yeah, I got manhandled right there.
是的，我刚才被欺负了。
I know. We saw that.
我知道。我们看到了。
But the rookie players come through with some surprises. For instance, at the very same moment that the coaches are grumbling to themselves about where exactly freshman Allan Vallalta is heading on the field, Vallalta recovers a fumble.
但菜鸟球员带来了一些惊喜。例如，就在教练们私下抱怨一年级新生艾伦·瓦拉尔塔在球场上到底要去向哪里时，瓦拉尔塔抢到了一个掉球。
Oh, god. Vallalta's on the way. [BLEEP]. Oh, damn. He just made a play. He just made a damn play.
噢，天哪。瓦拉尔塔在路上。[哔]。噢，该死。他刚才完成了一个精彩动作。他刚才完成了一个该死的精彩动作。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
By the end of the first half, it's Tigers 7, Bearcats 6.
上半场结束时，老虎队7比6领先野猫队。
Good job, Walt. That a boy. Good job.
做得好，沃尔特。好孩子。做得好。
The home bleachers are pretty packed by now. And the thing I realized when I start talking to people is that this is the first time this town has gotten together since the hurricane. One of the first people I meet, Gary Yarborough, doesn't even have a kid on the team.
现在主场看台已经挤满了人。当我开始和人们交谈时，我意识到这是自飓风以来这个城镇第一次聚在一起。我遇到的第一个人之一，加里·亚伯勒，甚至都没有孩子在球队里。
I'm just out here just trying to see who's still here, and who's still in town, and visit with the other folks, and kind of see how everybody's handling everything and dealing with everything.
我只是出来想看看谁还在，谁还在镇上，和别的人拜访一下，看看每个人是如何处理一切和应对一切的。
Is this the first time you're seeing a lot of folks in a while?
这是你很久以来第一次看到很多人吗？
Yeah, some of them. Yeah. Because with the curfews and nothing open in town, there's really no place to go to see anybody.
是的，有些人。是的。因为有宵禁，镇上什么都不开，真的没有地方可以去见任何人。
As I walk through the stands, the one thing people keep telling me is what a normal night this is, what a relief it is to do something normal again. You talk to anyone for more than a couple minutes, and what you hear next is just how far from normal everything is. They're worried about flood insurance, and FEMA trailers, and whether they'll have jobs. I ask one man, the booster club president, what the highlight of the game is so far, and he nearly starts to cry.
当我走过看台时，人们一直告诉我的一件事是这是一个多么正常的夜晚，再次做一些正常的事情是一种多么大的解脱。你和任何人谈话超过几分钟，你接下来听到的就是一切离正常有多远。他们担心洪水保险、FEMA拖车，以及他们是否会有工作。我问一个人，后援会主席，目前为止比赛的亮点是什么，他几乎要哭了。
Turn it up!
加大音量！
Down on the field, the Tigers are playing better than anyone had expected. Going into the fourth quarter, the score is 21-6, Tigers comfortably leading. But then in the last five minutes of the game, everything falls apart. The Bearcats' star player, Tramaine Brock, rushes for a touchdown. They miss the extra point, so it's 21-12. Two minutes later, with just three minutes left in the game, Brock sprints 55 yards to the end zone as the Tiger coaches watch helplessly.
在球场上，老虎队打得比任何人预期的都要好。进入第四节，比分是21比6，老虎队舒服地领先。但在比赛的最后五分钟，一切都崩溃了。野猫队的明星球员特拉梅因·布洛克冲球达阵。他们错过了额外分，所以是21比12。两分钟后，离比赛结束还有三分钟时，布洛克冲刺了55码进入达阵区，老虎队教练无助地看着。
That's it. He's gone. [BLEEP]. He's gone.
就是这样。他走了。[哔]。他走了。
They catch another and run. They score.
他们抓住另一个并跑动。他们得分了。
Ah! Dang it.
啊！该死。
[WHISTLE BLOWING]
[哨声响起]
It's a two-point game now, 21-19. The Tigers are still leading, but Long Beach has the momentum, and they only need a field goal to win. The Tigers are completely exhausted. Many have been on the field the entire game, the kickers limping. Alan Vallalta, the ninth grader who made that great play, is on the sidelines with an injured knee. The Tigers get the ball back, their last possession, but they can't even manage a first down. They punt it away, and there's still plenty of time for Long Beach to score.
现在是两分的差距，21比19。老虎队仍然领先，但长滩有势头，他们只需要一个射门就能赢。老虎队完全精疲力尽。许多人整场比赛都在场上，踢球手一瘸一拐。完成那个精彩动作的一年级学生艾伦·瓦拉尔塔因膝伤在场边。老虎队拿回了球，这是他们最后一次进攻机会，但他们甚至无法获得第一档。他们弃踢，长滩仍然有充足的时间得分。
[SHOUTING]
[呼喊]
Don't let him behind. Don't worry about the first.
别让他落后。别担心第一档。
Everything you've got right now!
把你现在拥有的一切都拿出来！
Be ready to drop.
准备好下潜。
The Bearcats start to drive again. They cross the 50-yard line into Bay High territory. The clock is running down. Coaches are screaming.
野猫队开始再次推进。他们越过50码线进入湾区高中领地。时间在流逝。教练们在大喊大叫。
Jason, be ready to drop. Here we go. Here we go.
杰森，准备下潜。我们走吧。我们走吧。
The place is going nuts.
这个地方要疯了。
[CHANTING]
[呼喊]
I can honestly say this is the only football game I've ever been to where it really did seem to matter who won. Earlier, I felt bad taking sides against the Bearcats. Their town was hit by the hurricane too.
我可以诚实地说这是我参加过的唯一一场我认为谁赢真的很重要的橄榄球比赛。早些时候，我因为站在野猫队的对立面而感到糟糕。他们的城镇也受到了飓风的袭击。
But now I don't know what I'll do if the Tigers lose. Their town was hit harder. They're the underdogs. They have to win.
但现在我不知道如果老虎队输了我会做什么。他们的城镇受灾更严重。他们是弱者。他们必须赢。
And then they do. They stop the Bearcats. It's over.
然后他们做到了。他们阻止了野猫队。结束了。
[SHOUTING AND CHEERING]
[呼喊和欢呼]
Tiger defense.
老虎队防守。
Shake it up. Shake it up. Shake it up.
摇晃它。摇晃它。摇晃它。
The clock runs out, and the place explodes. 21-19 Tigers. It's every corny sports movie come to life-- people streaming on the field, hugging, players sprawled on the ground, all these people in this wrecked town ecstatic over a football game. Assistant Coach Jeremy Turcotte.
时间到了，这个地方爆炸了。21比19老虎队。这就像每一部俗气的体育电影变成现实——人们涌向球场，拥抱，球员们瘫倒在地上，这个被毁坏的小镇里的所有这些人对一场橄榄球比赛感到狂喜。助理教练杰里米·图尔科特。
I think next to getting married and having my baby, that's about the most amazing thing I've ever seen in my life.
我认为除了结婚和生孩子，那是我一生中见过的最神奇的事情。
Hey, guys. Listen up. I'm going to let you go. I know we got to get home.
嘿，伙计们。听着。我要让你们走。我知道我们得回家。
Coach Compretta.
康普雷塔教练。
Never been more proud, OK, in my coaching career, never been more proud of a group of guys in my life than right now. Love you guys. I love you guys.
从来没有更自豪过，好吗，在我的教练生涯中，从来没有比现在更对我一生中的一群人感到自豪。爱你们，伙计们。我爱你们，伙计们。
Take tomorrow off. See you on Wednesday, 3:30. Be here for 3:30, OK? Everybody touch somebody. Great job, fellas. Great job, fellas.
明天休息。周三见，3点30分。3点30分到这里，好吗？每个人都触碰一下别人。做得好，伙计们。做得好，伙计们。
Break it down! One time win!
打破它！赢一次！
Bay St. Louis and Hancock County is still under a curfew, ladies and gentlemen. After the game, you'll need to go home as soon as possible.
圣路易斯湾和汉考克县仍然处于宵禁中，女士们，先生们。比赛结束后，你们需要尽快回家。
And just like that, the place clears out. A half hour later, the only people left are the coaches, still reliving the game. Luke, one of the assistants, is on the cell phone with his brother in Alabama.
就这样，这个地方清空了。半小时后，剩下的人只有教练，仍然在重温比赛。卢克，助手之一，正在和他在阿拉巴马州的兄弟通电话。
They had the ball with about a minute and a half left, driving with no time outs. And we sacked them with no time left. But I just wanted to call and tell you that, man. I'll call you tomorrow sometime. I just wanted to holler at you real quick. I love you, brother. Bye. Bye.
他们在大约一分半钟时拿到球，没有暂停在推进。我们在没有时间的情况下对他进行了擒杀。但我只是想打电话告诉你，伙计。我明天什么时候给你打电话。我只是想很快和你大喊大叫。爱你，兄弟。再见。再见。
Of all the coaches I met here, Luke seemed the most discouraged about everything. He'd lost his house. He sounded disheartened. In the morning, he told me that when his contract is up in May, he'll probably leave here. But now his mood is different.
在我在这里遇到的所有教练中，卢克似乎对一切都最灰心。他失去了他的房子。他听起来很沮丧。早上，他告诉我当他在五月的合同时到期时，他可能会离开这里。但现在他的心情不同了。
We play next Friday night here. And it's not like the town's going to be back to normal next Friday night. So I mean, they're still going to not have anything to do. There's still going to be a curfew.
我们下周五晚上在这里比赛。下周五晚上这个小镇也不会恢复正常。所以我的意思是，他们仍然会没事做。仍然会有宵禁。
And I mean, this just starts it. I mean, if you lose tonight, it's like, you know what? You go home, and you're sitting in a trailer, and you have no AC, and you lost a football game. But it's a little easier to go home and sit in a trailer with no AC when you just won a football game that nobody gave you a chance to win.
我的意思是，这只是开始。我的意思是，如果你今晚输了，就像，你知道吗？你回家了，你坐在一辆拖车里，你没有空调，你输掉了一场橄榄球比赛。但当你刚刚赢了一场没人给你机会赢的橄榄球比赛时，回家坐在没有空调的拖车里会容易一点。
Before coming to Bay St. Louis, I felt the way I think a lot of us feel when we see these places on TV. I didn't understand how you go back to a town like that, to all that loss, and live there in the middle of it. What are you going back there for, and how do you even begin to get over it? Watching the Tigers win 21-19, completely outmatched, everyone together cheering them on, I knew the answer.
在来到圣路易斯湾之前，我的感觉就像我们很多人在电视上看到这些地方时的感觉。我不明白你怎么回到这样一个城镇，回到所有的那些损失，住在它中间。你回去是为了什么，你甚至怎么开始克服它？看着老虎队21比19获胜，完全被压制，每个人都在欢呼，我知道了答案。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
Lisa Pollak. So we checked in this week with Tigers Coach Brenan Compretta. He is not the coach anymore, but is still very involved with the team. He told us that, in some ways, the pandemic has been harder on the high school kids in town than Katrina was. The kids facing Katrina, he said, could at least still hang out together.
丽莎·波拉克。所以本周我们和老虎队教练布雷南·康普雷塔进行了核实。他不再是教练了，但仍然非常参与球队。他告诉我们，在某些方面，疫情对镇上的高中生来说比卡特里娜飓风更难。他说，面对卡特里娜飓风的孩子们至少仍然可以聚在一起。
Right now, the school plans to be open in the fall. The team is supposed to start summer workouts in about a week, June 1, with the first game scheduled for August. That's the plan for now anyway.
目前，学校计划在秋季开放。球队应该在大约一周后，6月1日开始夏季训练，第一场比赛定于8月。总之，那是目前的计划。
[MUSIC - "BACKFIELD IN MOTION" BY MEL AND TIM]
[音乐 - Mel and Tim的"BACKFIELD IN MOTION"]
Act Two, Dunk and Go Nuts. So back in 1996, when Michael Jordan and the Chicago Bulls were at the height of their power on the way to winning the fourth of the six championships that they won back in the '90s, we did an episode of our show on the Bulls and just about loving basketball. It included the story of a barber named Tommy, who was the one person rooting against the Bulls in a barber shop on the South Side full of Bulls fanatics, as they all watched the playoff game on television, the Bulls against Shaquille O'Neal and the Orlando Magic.
第二幕，扣篮和疯狂。所以早在1996年，当迈克尔·乔丹和芝加哥公牛队在90年代赢得的六个冠军中的第四个冠军的路上处于权力的顶峰时，我们做了一集关于公牛队以及只是关于热爱篮球的节目。它包括了一个叫汤米的理发师的故事，他是南区满是公牛队狂热粉丝的理发店里唯一一个支持公牛队对手的人，他们都在电视上观看季后赛，公牛队对阵沙奎尔·奥尼尔和奥兰多魔术队。
I like Shaq.
我喜欢沙克。
Yeah.
是的。
And they're having a rough time at the moment.
他们现在正经历一段艰难时期。
Yeah.
是的。
But can't give up the shift yet. That's right. Can't give up the shift.
但还不能放弃换档。没错。不能放弃换档。
Even at halftime, the Bulls up by 10, Tommy did not let up. Scissors in hand, a toothpick dangling from his lip, he declared--
即使在中场休息时，公牛队领先10分，汤米也没有放弃。手中拿着剪刀，嘴唇上悬着一根牙签，他宣称——
Orlando's coming back, win by five. It ain't over till the fat lady sings.
奥兰多会回来的，赢五分。没到胖女人唱完，一切都没结束。
I think it was just funny to him to calmly say no to a room full of hyped-up fans. Later, when the game ended and the Bulls won by 15, Tommy insisted, no biggie. The Bulls would lose the coming series against Seattle. And then-- OK, this is the scene I narrated back then in that show.
我想他冷静地对满屋子兴奋的球迷说“不”很有趣。后来，比赛结束公牛队赢了15分时，汤米坚持说，没关系。公牛队会在即将到来的对阵西雅图的系列赛中输掉。然后——好吧，这就是我当时在那个节目中叙述的场景。
Then we all looked up. And through the plate glass window in front of the barber shop, we saw a car pull up. A guy climbs out with a brand new broom in his hand and strides towards the barber shop.
然后我们都抬头看。透过理发店前面的平板玻璃窗，我们看到一辆车停了下来。一个家伙手里拿着一把崭新的扫帚爬了出来，大步走向理发店。
He's bringing the broom to Tommy.
他要把扫帚带给汤米。
The guy walks in and stands, broom in hand, near the door.
那个人走进门，手里拿着扫帚，站在门附近。
What's the problem?
问题是什么？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I told y'all I was going to come back up here now.
我告诉过你们所有人我现在要回这里来。
Hey, Tommy. You didn't think that was going to sweep, huh? [LAUGHS]
嘿，汤米。你没想到那会扫吧，嗯？[笑]
It ain't no sweep.
那不是横扫。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Tommy, I can't hear you, man. Did you see the bull run down the street? Was Shaquille on it?
汤米，我听不见你说话，伙计。你看到那只公牛跑下街了吗？沙奎尔在上面吗？
The guy's name is Derek, a regular at Coleman's.
那个人叫德里克，是科尔曼理发店的常客。
Tell him I got to go home and celebrate, man. Me and all my Bull friend buddies, we finna go celebrate. You're going to jump on the bandwagon sooner or later, Tommy. We're going to make a believer out of you.
告诉他我得回家庆祝了，伙计。我和我所有的公牛队朋友伙伴，我们要去庆祝。你迟早会跳上花车的，汤米。我们要让你成为信徒。
Tommy's unnerved.
汤米心烦意乱。
I've already talked to Gary Payton. And boy, we're going to do it in 4-2-- Gary Payton, Seattle. [CHUCKLES]
我已经和加里·佩顿谈过了。伙计，我们要以4比2赢下它——加里·佩顿，西雅图。[轻笑]
That episode of the show wasn't just about being a basketball fan. It was also about playing basketball and what it can mean to you-- and not incidentally, all the trophies that you collect along the way if you're serious about the game. Further you get, the bigger the trophy. Of course, some trophies do not age very well. Get old enough and, at some point, they can just start to look like dusty, aging clutter. One of our producers, Nancy Updike, talked to a friend of hers who played a lot of basketball all about this.
那集节目不仅仅是关于成为篮球迷。它也是关于打篮球以及它对你意味着什么——顺便说一句，如果你认真对待这个游戏，你一路上收集的所有奖杯。你走得越远，奖杯就越大。当然，有些奖杯老化得不是很好。年纪足够大，在某个时候，它们可能看起来只是布满灰尘、老化的杂物。我们的一位制片人南希·厄普代克和她的一个朋友谈到了这些。
When I met up with my friend Mary to talk about basketball, she was having some trouble with her trophies. She just moved to a new apartment. And her new place was small, so small that a bunch of high school trophies would just dominate any room they were in.
当我见到我的朋友玛丽谈论篮球时，她的奖杯遇到了一些麻烦。她刚搬到一套新公寓。她的新家很小，小到一群高中奖杯会占据它们所在房间的任何位置。
She had the trophies in a box in the living room. And we sat on the floor, pulling out fake silver statuettes of girls in culottes reaching ever upward, hopeful and fit, like in Soviet propaganda posters.
她把奖杯放在客厅的一个盒子里。我们坐在地板上，掏出女孩们穿着裙裤的假银色小雕像，向上伸展，充满希望和健康，就像苏联宣传海报上的一样。
See, can't you see feeling really tough walking home with something this big, especially if you hold it like this?
你看，你看不出拿着这么大的东西走回家会感觉很硬吗，尤其是如果你这样拿着它？
Sure. Grab that baby by the base.
当然。抓住那个底座。
Yeah.
是的。
Then she found one that was not like the others, sort of hard to understand, actually. Picture this, a thick slice of wood, sanded and shellacked, and mounted with a miniature rim and backboard, and then leaping across the front a stick figure made of roofing nails going in for a slam dunk. Mary identified this as her 1978 girls varsity team trophy from Cardinal Dougherty High School. And the girls, she said, had not been pleased with the trophy at all.
然后她发现了一个和其他人不同的，实际上有点难以理解。想象一下，一块厚厚的木片，打磨和涂了虫胶，装上了一个微型篮圈和篮板，然后在前面跳跃的是一个由屋顶钉子制成的火柴人，准备扣篮。玛丽认定这是她1978年卡迪纳尔·多尔蒂高中女子校队的奖杯。她说，女孩们对这个奖杯一点也不满意。
It's ugly, isn't it?
它很丑，不是吗？
Yeah, it is truly-- it's so damned--
是的，它确实——它太该死的——
We were all really unhappy. We wanted a traditional--
我们都非常不开心。我们想要一个传统的——
Will you give it to me?
你会把它给我吗？
Yes. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑]
I want it. I want it.
我想要它。我想要它。
We would rather have had the also ugly, but much more acceptable, old version of trophies then than those trophies.
比起那些奖杯，我们宁愿要那个同样丑陋但更可接受的旧奖杯。
Oh, sure. Oh, sure. I mean, if you're a 13-year-old girl, you don't want to be walking home with that. You want that.
噢，当然。噢，当然。我的意思是，如果你是一个13岁的女孩，你不想带着那个走回家。你想要那个。
No. Right, right.
不。对，对。
That's a trophy.
那是一个奖杯。
You want something that goes up high in the sky, not something that is a slice of a tree.
你想要一个在天空中升得很高，而不是一个是一棵树的切片的东西。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You don't want a tree slice.
你不想树切片。
A slice of a tree with a nail stick figure soldered together, doing the one thing that you know you'll never be able to do-- dunk.
一个带有钉子火柴人焊接在一起的树切片，做着你唯一知道你永远无法做到的事情——扣篮。
Was that something that you all discussed?
那是你们大家讨论过的事情吗？
Oh, yeah. And we also thought that that was the only reason we'd never be in the NBA. Luckily for us, we all thought, well, we're really some of the best players on the face of the Earth. When you're a 16-year-old girl who's playing at a tough Catholic league school, you think, yeah, we're good enough. I'm just as good as Maurice Cheeks, and the Doctor would like to play with me, Dr. J. And we could attribute our lack of success in the NBA to the fact that we were girls, soon to be women, who had never dunked. And that's all that was keeping us from it.
噢，是的。而且我们也认为那是我们永远不会进入NBA的唯一原因。幸运的是，我们都认为，好吧，我们真的是地球上最好的球员之一。当你是一个在艰难的天主教联赛学校打球的16岁女孩时，你会想，是的，我们足够好了。我和莫里斯·奇克斯一样好，J博士愿意和我一起打球。我们可以将我们在NBA的缺乏成功归因于我们是女孩，很快成为女人，从未扣过篮。这就是阻止我们进入NBA的唯一原因。
Mary handed me the wood slice trophy. And when I reached to touch the stick figure, I realized that one of its feet was on a pivot. So I could actually make it go in for the dunk. Once I discovered this, it was impossible not to do it over, and over, and over. The trophy was completely hypnotizing, a disturbing artifact from an artistic period best forgotten.
玛丽把木切片奖杯递给我。当我伸手去触摸那个火柴人时，我意识到它的脚有一个枢轴。所以我实际上可以让它去扣篮。一旦我发现了这一点，就不可能不做一遍又一遍。这个奖杯完全令人着迷，这是一个来自最好被遗忘的艺术时期的令人不安的文物。
The art of the late '70s, especially like in Catholic religion textbooks and churches and stuff, was so ugly.
70年代末的艺术，特别是像天主教宗教教科书和教堂里的东西，太丑了。
Who knew there was even a genre, the late '70s Catholic textbook art world, that whole scene?
谁知道甚至有一个流派，70年代末天主教教科书艺术世界，整个场景？
I'm afraid I've been so influenced by it. It's like, you know--
恐怕我已经受到它的影响了。就像，你知道——
I need to walk away.
我需要走开。
--those little ink drawings that are just a little bit off on purpose. You know what I mean? And the unpurposeness of it is just like, you know--
——那些故意有点偏离的小墨水画。你知道我的意思吗？而且它的非目的性就像，你知道——
It makes you want to grit your teeth.
它让你想咬牙切齿。
Oh, help me. Yeah, right, right. You can always hear a Cat Stevens song playing in the background.
噢，救救我。是的，对，对。你总能在背景中听到一首卡特·史蒂文斯的歌。
As a kid, Mary played basketball mostly with her older brother, Daniel. The two of them roamed around the city together, looking for pickup games whenever they could, all summer, every weekend-- even at night, because the court down the street had lights. It was a way to get out of the house, to escape the chaos of 11 kids in a working class Irish family in a too-small house on the edge of Northeast Philadelphia. Basketball was a place of clear rules and gestures that always made sense. And home was a place where you could get hit for no reason or find yourself still hungry at the end of a meal. Mary remembered being hungry a lot growing up, a fact always cheerfully denied by the nuns at school.
小时候，玛丽主要和她的哥哥丹尼尔一起打篮球。他们俩在城里到处游荡，寻找任何他们能找到的街球游戏，整个夏天，每个周末——甚至在晚上，因为街下的球场有灯光。这是一种逃离房子的方式，逃离费城东北部边缘一个小房子里11个孩子在工人阶级爱尔兰家庭中的混乱。篮球是一个有清晰规则和动作的地方，总是说得通。家是一个你可能无缘无故被打，或者发现自己在饭后仍然感到饥饿的地方。玛丽记得长大后经常感到饥饿，这是一个学校修女总是愉快否认的事实。
The message was you couldn't be hungry, because your parents are saints. And they especially directed it to our family and to all the other families that had a lot of kids in them, that our parents were saints because they worked so hard to provide for us. So I thought that I was just extraordinarily greedy that I would want to eat when I was hungry.
信息是你不能感到饥饿，因为你的父母是圣人。他们特别针对我们的家庭和所有其他有很多孩子的家庭，说我们的父母是圣人，因为他们为了供养我们工作得如此努力。所以我以为我只是特别贪婪，我才会在感到饥饿时想吃东西。
I think that playing basketball was a way to say, like, if I could use my body in this way that got me status and attention and a certain amount of prestige, then my body was OK in a way, even though it was-- I mean, I was way too skinny when I was a kid. And it was cause for concern for the school nurse a couple times. And playing basketball was a way to say you're not going to have neural damage from being malnourished. You're just going to have these other minor malnourished problems.
我认为打篮球是一种说，比如，如果我能以这种方式使用我的身体，让我获得地位和注意力和一定程度的声望，那么我的身体在某种程度上还可以，即使它是——我的意思是，我小时候太瘦了。学校护士有几次很担心。打篮球是一种说你不会因为营养不良而造成神经损伤的方式。你只会遇到这些其他轻微的营养不良问题。
Another good thing about basketball was that it was cheap. Mary bought the family a rim and a basketball for their backyard when she was only seven or eight, using her first communion money, $65 in $5 increments from everyone in her huge family. The only equipment she really needed and could never afford were good shoes. She always had those supermarket checkout line shoes with the hard plastic soles that were completely embarrassing, of course, but also had no gripability. So she would be running down the court and go sliding, and be called for traveling. So one year, she got up the courage to ask a girl down the block for her old shoes.
篮球的另一个好处是它很便宜。玛丽在七八岁时用她的第一次圣餐钱，从她庞大家庭中的每个人那里获得65美元，每人5美元，给他们的后院买了一个篮圈和篮球。她真正需要且永远买不起的唯一装备是好鞋。她总是穿着那些超市结账台的硬塑料底鞋，当然完全令人尴尬，但也根本没有抓地力。所以她在球场上跑动时会滑倒，并被判走步。所以有一年，她鼓起勇气向街头的女孩要她的旧鞋。
Her name was Karen. And she had really nice Beta Bullets, high tops, white. And I wanted her sneakers because I knew she was getting new ones. And in our neighborhood, there is the practice of throwing your old sneakers up over the telephone wires when you're done with them. And most of them were hardly worn out at all. I mean, a lot of them you could see that there was tread missing, but it's not like you had ripped through the top of them.
她的名字叫凯伦。她有非常好的贝塔子弹鞋，高帮，白色的。我想要她的运动鞋，因为我知道她要买新的。在我们的社区，有当用完运动鞋后把旧运动鞋扔到电话线上的做法。它们中的大多数几乎没有磨损。我的意思是，你可以看到缺少胎面，但并不像你已经撕破了它们的顶部。
And I'd asked her for them. And she said, yeah, that she would give them to me when she got her new ones. I thought that it was a little bit weird that I would ask somebody for their used shoes, but we had other clothes that were used from other people.
我向她要了它们。她说，是的，她会在得到新鞋时把它们给我。我觉得向别人要他们用过的鞋子有点奇怪，但我们确实有从别人那里用过的其他衣服。
And she was tough, and she kind of had this like, you know-- she seemed like she'd be the kind of person that could keep something like that to her and would know what it meant. And she did. She never told anybody, except, of course, the most important person that she shouldn't have told, her mother. And her mother got really upset and told her that she couldn't give them to me. And there they were, hanging up on the telephone wire, my sneakers.
而且她很强硬，她看起来像那种能把这种事情藏在心里并知道它意味着什么的人。她确实做了。她从未告诉任何人，当然，除了她不应该告诉的最重要的人，她的母亲。她的母亲非常生气，告诉她不能把它们给我。它们就在那里，挂在电话线上，我的运动鞋。
And I'm sure that her mom did that because she was afraid that if I came home with a pair of used sneakers that it would be insulting to my mother. I'm sure that they all had this understanding of themselves. Like, you don't insult someone else's-- you don't insult one of your peers by giving their kids your crappy shoes, even though they're better than the crappy shoes that you bought for them. [CHUCKLES]
我相信她的妈妈这样做是因为她害怕如果我带着一双旧运动鞋回家，那会侮辱我的母亲。我相信他们对自己都有这种理解。比如，你不侮辱别人的——你不侮辱你的同龄人，给他们的孩子你烂鞋，即使它们比你买给他们的烂鞋更好。[轻笑]
But there were always really beautiful sneakers hanging up on the wires. And there was no way to get them, no way at all. They just floated up there. And you know what? I think that's when I decided that platonic idealism was true.
但电话线上总是挂着非常漂亮的运动鞋。没有办法得到它们，一点办法都没有。它们只是漂浮在那里。你知道吗？我想那时我决定柏拉图理想主义是真的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There really was a perfect thing that I would never experience, at least while I played in that Catholic league. [LAUGHS]
确实有一个完美的东西，我永远不会经历，至少在我那个天主教联赛打球时是这样。[笑]
And only I could see them for what they were. They only saw worn-out tread. I saw a season of unforeseen high statistics.
而且只有我能看出它们是什么。他们只看到磨损的胎面。我看到一个未预见的高统计数据的赛季。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We talked for two hours about basketball, and we kept returning to the dunk and the cruelty of the dunk on that wood slice trophy, a dunk by a stick figure made of nails, driving home their 18-year-old sense of frustration. They could be the best ball handlers, the best guards, and it didn't matter worth a damn because they couldn't dunk, all of that captured forever in the last trophy most of them would ever receive.
我们谈论了两个小时关于篮球，我们不断回到扣篮和那个木片奖杯上扣篮的残酷，一个由钉子制成的火柴人的扣篮，驱使着他们18岁时那种沮丧的感觉。他们可以是最好的控球手，最好的后卫，这无关紧要，因为他们不能扣篮，所有这些都被记录在他们大多数人将收到的最后一个奖杯中。
I think it was really kind of thoughtless in the way that thoughtless things can sometimes have a really nasty edge to them. And we had a woman on our team who was like 6' 3", and she couldn't dunk the ball. You know what I mean? It was like, there was no one that we knew who could dunk the ball, not a single woman that we knew. And we knew some tall women. We knew women who were in college. I mean, I used to have a dream, a recurring dream that I dunked the ball.
我认为这在那种没头没脑的事情有时能有非常令人讨厌的边缘的方式上是非常没头没脑的。我们队有一个身高6英尺3英寸的女人，她不能扣篮。你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，我们认识的人中没有人能扣篮，我们认识的任何女人都没有。我们认识一些高个子女性。我们认识上大学的女性。我的意思是，我过去经常做一个梦，一个我扣篮的反复梦。
What were the circumstances?
情况是什么？
I was on the baseline. [LAUGHS]
我在底线。[笑]
I'm so glad you asked.
我很高兴你问了。
I mean, it was the same-- I was in the same position all the time. And it wasn't like the kinds of dunks that you see in real life that even the best players can do. This was a spectacular dunk because I didn't just get my hands up over the rim, I sailed over the rim with my feet and got above the basket, and just slammed the ball down through the thing. My whole body was above the rim.
我的意思是，它是一样的——我一直处于同一个位置。而且这不像你在现实生活中看到的即使是最好的球员也能做的那种扣篮。这是一个壮观的扣篮，因为我不只是把手举过篮圈，我带着我的脚航行过篮圈，到达篮筐上方，然后把球砰地一声灌进那个东西里。我的整个身体都在篮筐上方。
Wow.
哇。
It stayed in bounds the whole time.
它一直都在界内。
Mary Conway talking with our own Nancy Updike. Coming up, a kid who's not great at soccer invents a way to be a star. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
玛丽·康威与我们自己的南希·厄普代克交谈。接下来，一个不擅长足球的孩子发明了一种成为明星的方法。那在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Time Out." In this kind of unprecedented moment when sports have been put on pause, like when has that ever happened? We had favorite stories from back before the lockdown to fill in the void, the sports void. We have arrived at Act Three of our program-- Act Three, Those Who Can't Play.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“暂停”。在这种前所未有的时刻，体育比赛被搁置了，那种情况曾经发生过吗？我们有来自封锁前的最爱故事来填补空白，体育空白。我们已经到达了我们节目的第三幕——第三幕，那些不会玩的人。
OK. So, so far on our show, we've done football and basketball. Let's turn to soccer. This is from Daniel Alarcon, the executive producer and host of Radio Ambulante. And it's about his dad. Growing up in Peru, Daniel's dad, Renato, played soccer around the neighborhood like all the kids did, but he was never anything special.
好的。所以，到目前为止在我们的节目中，我们已经讲了橄榄球和篮球。让我们转向足球。这是来自Radio Ambulante的执行制片人和主持人丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔。这是关于他父亲的故事。在秘鲁长大，丹尼尔的父亲雷纳托像所有孩子一样在社区里踢足球，但他从来不是什么特别的人。
So it was certain, like, he was never thought of as being an athlete.
所以可以肯定，就像，他从来没有被认为是运动员。
But he was thought of, from a young age, as being beyond unusually bright.
但他从小就被认为不仅是异常聪明。
When I've gone back, I was introduced as, oh, this is Renato's son. And then just heard, like, a-- just, oh, your dad was so smart. Your dad was so smart. When he was a kid, he won this-- he was, like, 14. He won this national quiz show for kids on TV.
当我回去时，我被介绍为，噢，这是雷纳托的儿子。然后只是听到，比如，一个——噢，你爸爸太聪明了。你爸爸太聪明了。他小时候，他赢了这个——他就像，14岁。他赢了这个国家电视上的儿童知识问答节目。
Oh, wow.
噢，哇。
Flew from the city where he lived in, flew to Lima. He was the only kid from the provinces who was a finalist, only kid from a public school-- front page of the newspaper.
从他居住的城市飞过来，飞到利马。他是来自各省的决赛选手中唯一的孩子，唯一的公立学校孩子——报纸头版。
He was incredibly verbal kid, loved poetry and words, great talker. But again, soccer.
他是一个极其健谈的孩子，热爱诗歌和文字，伟大的谈话者。但再次，足球。
There's two things that happen when you aren't one of the better players. They put you in goal, to be a goalkeeper. Maybe they might make you ref, but that's really, like, low, you know?
当你不是更好的球员时，有两件事会发生。他们让你去守门，做守门员。也许他们可能会让你当裁判，但那真的就像，很低，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
But my dad turned that around and wasn't goalie or ref. And I'm sure he played. I'm not saying that he didn't play. But he started calling the neighborhood games.
但我爸爸改变了这一点，不是守门员或裁判。我相信他踢过球。我不是说他没玩。但他开始呼叫社区比赛。
Wait, wait. So he was calling the games. Did he have gear?
等等，等等。所以他在呼叫比赛。他有装备吗？
He had a microphone and a little speaker.
他有一个麦克风和一个小扬声器。
He could make his voice louder--
他可以使他的声音更大——
Yeah. He could make it, when he's--
是的。他可以，当他——
--when he's outside.
——当他在外面。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
And so basically he's just taking equipment down, and he's announcing kids' actual games--
所以基本上他只是拿下装备，他在呼叫孩子们的真实比赛——
Yes.
是的。
--as they're playing?
——当他们比赛时？
Yes.
是的。
Like, kids he knows?
比如，他认识的孩子？
Yeah, kids in his neighborhood.
是的，他社区里的孩子。
I would just imagine, like, if I were a kid playing in that game, to have somebody calling the game and I could hear them calling the game as I was doing it, it would make me so much more competitive. You know what I mean? It makes it so much more epic.
我可以想象，比如，如果我是一个在那场比赛中踢球的孩子，有某人在呼叫比赛，而我在做这件事时能听到他们在呼叫比赛，它会让我变得更有竞争力。你知道我的意思吗？它让它变得更加史诗。
Yeah, absolutely. My picture of it is like, how glamorous. Are you kidding me? Like, suddenly their game is elevated, and it's not just a neighborhood game now. It's like, look, this is just like we're on the radio, which is just like-- that's the same they do for the World Cup.
是的，绝对。我对它的画面就像，多么迷人。你在跟我开玩笑吗？就像，突然间他们的比赛被提升了，现在它不再只是社区比赛了。就像，看，这就像我们在广播里一样，这和他们为世界杯所做的一样。
Daniel's dad would also make up games-- like whole professional games, like all the players, both sides, all the action-- starting, Daniel says, when he was 10 or 11. He would do it just kind of for himself as, like, a thing to do, though the whole family knew he could do this.
丹尼尔的父亲也会编造比赛——比如整个职业比赛，比如所有球员，双方，所有动作——丹尼尔说，从他10岁或11岁时开始。他会这样做就像为了自己作为，比如，要做的一件事，尽管全家人都知道他能做到这一点。
And if-- for example, on a Sunday afternoon after everyone's had lunch, my father would start to be the entertainment for the adults. Hey, Renato. Can you make up a game for us? Make it a good one. And he would just describe a game.
如果——例如，在大家都吃完午饭后的一个周日下午，我父亲会开始成为成年人的娱乐。嘿，雷纳托。你能为我们编造一场比赛吗？让它成为一场好比赛。他就会描述一场比赛。
And it's a completely made up game, but when a goal would be scored inevitably, the adults would cheer, and like, oh, that was great. That was a great game. And he got really good at this.
这是一场完全编造的比赛，但当一个进球不可避免地产生时，成年人会欢呼，就像，噢，那太棒了。那是一场精彩的比赛。他在这方面变得非常擅长。
One of my great uncles had a little theater in a town called Mollendo on the beach, a beach town in southern Peru. And they were doing sort of, like, a night of arts and poetry or whatever-- a talent show essentially, yeah. And my Great-Uncle Juan Castor signed up my dad and was like, you're going to do it just like you do for us.
我的一位伯祖父在秘鲁南部海滩的一个叫莫伦多的城镇有一个小剧场。他们正在做比如，艺术和诗歌之夜之类的——本质上是才艺秀，是的。我伯祖父胡安·卡斯托签下了我爸爸，就像，你将做它就像你为我们做的一样。
Around the house.
在房子周围。
Yeah.
是的。
On Sunday afternoons. And I think at that point, he was, like, 12 or 13. He goes out on stage, 300 people in the theater. And he's nervous, but what he does is essentially make up a game. So Melgar is the club from Arequipa.
在周日下午。我认为在那时，他就像，12岁或13岁。他走上舞台，剧场里有300人。他很紧张，但他所做的是本质上编造了一场比赛。所以梅尔加是来自阿雷基帕的俱乐部。
They're the local favorite from the province. And in this game that he made up on stage, they played the big, fancy team from the capital, Lima.
他们是来自省份的当地最爱。在这个他在舞台上编造的比赛中，他们对阵来自首都利马的大家伙，花哨的团队。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
They're like the Yankees.
他们就像洋基队。
They're like the Yankees, yeah. We don't like them. In his telling of it, everyone plays the game with their life. Everyone does it exactly right as if controlled by a marionette-- which, of course, they were.
他们就像洋基队，是的。我们不喜欢他们。在他的讲述中，每个人都用生命玩这个游戏。每个人都做得完全正确，就像被木偶操控一样——这，当然，他们是。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
I find it very easy to believe that people could have been really moved by the sport. It wasn't like a fake game. It was the game.
我发现很容易相信人们会被这项运动深深打动。这不是假比赛。这就是游戏。
And so in his game, the hometown team gets it up to the edge and scores?
所以在他的比赛中，家乡球队把它带到边缘并得分？
Yes. Melgar scores. People exploded, like you were cheering something that had actually happened. And the detail that he tells me that I'm always struck by is that when the lights came off and he went off stage, his uncle was crying, just weeping with joy and with, I guess, pride.
是的。梅尔加得分。人们爆炸了，就像你在欢呼一件真正发生过的事情。他告诉我让我印象深刻的细节是当灯光熄灭他走下舞台时，他的叔叔在哭，因为喜悦而哭泣，以及我猜，骄傲。
There's a video of you online with your dad on stage, and you tell this story. And then your dad comes up on stage, and then he calls a game.
网上有一个你和你爸爸在舞台上的视频，你讲述了这个故事。然后你爸爸走上舞台，然后他呼叫了一场比赛。
Yeah. He hadn't done this in like 50 years. But we threw a jersey on him, and he took the mic.
是的。他有50年没这样做过。但我们给他穿上球衣，他拿了麦克风。
And you threw in some stadium sound underneath for realism.
你在下面加了一些体育场声音以增加真实感。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
What's he saying?
他在说什么？
So he's-- a minute 40, I believe he said. A Peruvian team against a Brazilian team, and the Brazilian team is bringing the ball out of the back.
所以他正在——一分钟40秒，我相信他说了。秘鲁队对阵巴西队，巴西队正把球从后场带出来。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Nilton Santos, who was a Brazilian defender, kicking it out towards the right.
尼尔顿·桑托斯，他是巴西后卫，向右踢出去。
So these are teams from the '50s?
所以这是50年代的球队？
Yeah.
是的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Oh, OK. So [? Aguerea ?] was a midfielder, a Peruvian midfielder. He intercepts the ball here. So this is where things start shifting.
噢，好的。所以[？阿格雷拉？]是一名中场球员，一名秘鲁中场球员。他在这里拦截了球。所以这就是事情开始转变的地方。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So [? Aguerea ?] intercepts the ball and passes towards the right. This is actually a stroke of genius that's coming up.
所以[？阿格雷拉？]拦截球并向右传球。这实际上是一个即将到来的天才之举。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Short pass to Navarrete.
传给纳瓦雷特的短传。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He passes to [? Brandosino. ?]
他传给[？布兰多西诺。？]
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Chino Rivera heads it.
奇诺·里维拉头球。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
OK. So this is the part where I was like, Dad, you're really playing with our emotions here. In his telling, the ball hits the post. Chino Rivera heads the ball, and it hits off the post.
好的。所以这是我当时觉得就像，爸爸，你真的在玩弄我们的感情。在他的讲述中，球击中立柱。奇诺·里维拉头球，它从立柱上弹开。
So bounces back out.
所以弹回外面。
Right.
对。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Back in the field. [? Terry-- ?] [? Terry ?] scores.
回到场上。[？特里——？] [？特里？]得分。
Goal!
进球！
People are so excited.
人们太兴奋了。
Goal!
进球！
So many chills, man.
这么多寒颤，伙计。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Peru uno, Brazil zero!
秘鲁1，巴西0！
I feel excited.
我感到兴奋。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Goal!
进球！
That's great. That's great.
太棒了。太棒了。
See? It works.
看见了吗？它工作了。
It's funny to think that if he had actually been great at soccer, that moment on stage never would have happened.
认为如果他在足球方面真的很伟大，舞台上的那一刻就不会发生了，这很有趣。
Right, right. Yeah, yeah. I mean, they might have been singing songs about him.
对，对。是的，是的。我的意思是，他们可能一直在唱关于他的歌。
Oh, somebody else would be.
噢，别的人会是。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Some other kid would have been on stage.
别的孩子会在舞台上。
Yeah.
是的。
Daniel Alarcon. He first told this story on his show, Radio Ambulante. He's launched a new weekly podcast with news from Latin America called El Hilo. It's available wherever you get your podcasts.
丹尼尔·阿拉尔孔。他首先在他的节目Radio Ambulante中讲述了这个故事。他推出了一个新的每周播客，名为El Hilo，包含来自拉美的新闻。它在你获得播客的任何地方都有。
Act Four, The Girl With the Golden Gloves. So now we travel back in time to a sweaty gym in 1998. That's when this was first broadcast. It's about somebody with a complicated relationship with the sport she loves from Meema Spadola.
第四幕，拥有金手套的女孩。所以现在我们回到1998年的一家汗流浃背的健身房。那是这个第一次播出的时候。这是关于一个与她热爱的运动有复杂关系的人，来自米玛·斯帕多拉。
Maritza was an accountant, a financial analyst at a huge insurance company. She was living day-to-day like anybody else. Then she heard about this boxing class that was being offered at the company gym. Some guy named Milton was teaching.
玛丽扎是一名会计师，一家大型保险公司的财务分析师。她像其他人一样过着日子。然后她听说公司健身房正在提供这种拳击课程。一个叫米尔顿的家伙在教。
Maritza liked sports. She'd even taken an aerobic boxing class before. So she decided to go down and check it out.
玛丽扎喜欢体育。她甚至以前参加过有氧拳击课程。所以她决定去看看。
Here I am in a suit, coming in. It was the first time. I didn't have a chance to change. So I'm walking in all suited up.
我穿着西装，进来了。这是第一次。我没机会换衣服。所以我穿着全套西装走进来。
So Maritza comes up, and she's so short. She goes, I want to get rid of my stomach. I want to get rid of my gut.
所以玛丽扎来了，她太矮了。她说，我想摆脱我的肚子。我想摆脱我的肥肉。
She was so short. I look at her. And I go, honey, I teach boxing. This ain't boxing aerobics, aero boxing. If you want to come and dance around, jump around, I said, I'm not the guy for you. So this ain't what you want.
她太矮了。我看着她。我说，亲爱的，我教拳击。这不是拳击有氧，有氧拳击。如果你想来跳舞，跳来跳去，我说，我不是你要找的人。所以这不是你要的。
He wasn't even thinking about me. There's another girl who thinks this is aero-- I mean-- so I threw a punch. He goes, oh, you got a pretty good punch there. He goes, let me see what you got. Bam, bam.
他甚至没考虑我。还有另一个女孩以为这是有氧——我的意思是——所以我打了一拳。他去，噢，你那拳打得不错。他去，让我看看你有什么。砰，砰。
You got a pretty good punch there, he goes. But who taught you how to box? Two steps. Then he's, like, trying to fix me.
你打了一拳不错，他说。但谁教你怎么打拳？两步。然后他，就像，试图修理我。
I'm going to teach you how to weave. I'm going to shine you up like an old shoe and polish you up. He made me laugh. I thought it was amusing. I found it amusing.
我要教你怎么编织。我要像擦旧鞋一样把你擦亮，把你打磨好。他让我笑了。我觉得这很有趣。我觉得这很有趣。
It reminded me of watching the old movies. And this guy's telling me I'm like an old shoe. He's going to polish me. This guy's got an act.
这让我想起了看老电影。这家伙告诉我我像一只旧鞋子。他要擦亮我。这家伙有一套表演。
So I started working with her every day, come down with the pads, giving her combinations. And she started falling into place. So I was like, whoa.
所以我开始每天和她一起工作，带着垫子下来，给她组合拳。她开始就位。所以我就像，哇。
I said, you know something? I said, if I could bring you to my gym in Brooklyn, I said, you could win the New York City Golden Gloves. She goes, I can? I go, honey, what I got you doing right now, no girl fights the way you do right now.
我说，你知道吗？我说，如果我能带你去我在布鲁克林的健身房，我说，你可以赢得纽约市金手套奖。她去，我可以？我去，亲爱的，我现在让你做的，没有女孩像你这样打架。
So that's how it all started.
所以这就是一切开始的方式。
Every day after work in Manhattan, Maritza would take the subway all the way out to Brooklyn to train for three or four hours at Milton's gym and then go all the way back home to Queens. She spent her weekends at the gym. No one in her old life understood what she was doing. She'd grown up in the projects, put herself through college, gotten an MBA, held a good paying job, and here she was, back so close to the streets.
曼哈顿下班后，玛丽扎每天都会乘地铁一直到布鲁克林，在米尔顿的健身房训练三四个小时，然后一直回家到皇后区。她周末在健身房度过。她过去生活中的没人明白她在做什么。她在项目中长大，通过大学，获得MBA，拥有一份高薪工作，而这里她，回到了离街道如此近的地方。
When she got a broken nose and black eyes in the ring, she lied to her coworkers about it, didn't tell them she was boxing. Her parents didn't approve of women fighting. They were conservative, born in Puerto Rico. Her friends were suspicious of her weight loss. They accused her of being anorexic, infected with HIV, or addicted to drugs. But at the gym, everyone believed in her. Maritza was the only girl at Milton's, his first girl. So she'd spar with the men there.
当她在拳击场上折断鼻子并有黑眼圈时，她对同事撒谎，没告诉他们她在打拳。她的父母不赞成女性打架。他们是保守的，出生在波多黎各。她的朋友对她的体重减轻感到怀疑。他们指责她患有厌食症，感染HIV，或吸毒。但在健身房，每个人都相信她。玛丽扎是米尔顿唯一的女孩，他的第一个女孩。所以她会和那里的男人陪练。
She took Joey one day, and she was throwing nonstop combinations and punches repetitiously. There was an old man sitting down in a chair, and he goes, god damn, that boy can throw some punches. She had the head gear on. So when she finished, he came over and he goes, that's going to be one good damn fighter. That boy is going to be great.
她有一天带了乔伊，她重复地扔着不间断的组合拳。有个老人坐在椅子上，他去，该死，那男孩能扔几拳。她戴着头盔。所以当她完成时，他走过来他去，那将是一个不错的斗士。那男孩会很棒。
I go, I hate to tell you this. That's no guy. He goes, what do you mean that's no guy? Looked like a guy. I go, that's a girl. He goes, get out of here.
我去，我不愿告诉你这个。那不是家伙。他去，你什么意思那不是家伙？看起来像个家伙。我去，那是女孩。他去，离开这里。
So I said, Maritza, come here. So she came over to me, and I took off her head gear. I go, does she look like a girl now? He goes, oh.
所以我说，玛丽扎，过来。所以她走到我身边，我摘下了她的头盔。我去，她现在看起来像女孩吗？他去，噢。
Looking at Maritza, you probably wouldn't think boxer. She's small, just over 5 feet tall, and only 106 pounds. Her features are fine and delicate. But when she talks about her love for boxing, you can see her in the ring. She's radiant. It's like speaking to someone who's had a religious conversion.
看着玛丽扎，你可能不会想到拳击手。她很小，刚超过5英尺高，只有106磅。她的特征细腻而精致。但当她谈论她对拳击的热爱时，你可以看到她在拳击场。她容光焕发。这就像和一个经历过宗教皈依的人说话。
Boxing has shed a light on me. It's like my vision. It's like I just obtained a vision. It's like-- this is what I was put here for.
拳击照亮了我。这就像我的愿景。这就像我刚刚获得了一个愿景。这就像——这是我被放在这里的原因。
Ladies and gentlemen, tonight's next bout is the women's 106 pound class. The referee is Pete Santiago. In the gold corner, Maritza Arroyo from the Supreme Team Boxing Club. Arroyo is a financial analyst and a part-time personal trainer.
女士们，先生们，今晚的下一场比赛是女子106磅级。裁判是皮特·圣地亚哥。在金角落，来自Supreme Team Boxing Club的玛丽扎·阿罗约。阿罗约是一名财务分析师和兼职私人教练。
With Milton's training, Maritza was unbeatable. Within a year, she had taken all the amateur titles in New York. She won the Metros, the Empire States, and in '96 she won the biggest of all, the Golden Gloves in Madison Square Garden, a fight televised around the world, held in a ring where some of the greatest boxers in history have fought.
在米尔顿的训练下，玛丽扎是不可战胜的。一年之内，她拿下了纽约所有的业余冠军头衔。她赢得了大都会，帝国之州，在96年她赢得了最大的奖项，麦迪逊广场花园的金手套奖，一场向世界转播的比赛，在一个历史上最伟大的拳击手曾战斗过的拳击场举行。
Two straight left hands by Arroyo. And another straight left. Four straight left hands by Arroyo.
阿罗约的两记直左拳。还有一记直左拳。阿罗约的四记直左拳。
Maritza and I get together to watch the video of her '96 Golden Gloves win. The garden's packed. The crowd's going wild. Maritza's incredibly fast and beautiful in the ring. Watching her, you understand what it means to be a smart fighter. She's calculated.
玛丽扎和我聚在一起观看她96年赢得金手套的录像。花园挤满了人。人群疯狂了。玛丽扎在拳击场上难以置信地快速而美丽。看着她，你明白成为一个聪明的斗士意味着什么。她很算计。
The woman she's fighting is taller than she is, with longer arms. So Maritza ducks down low and jabs up to the body, choosing where she lands her punches-- to the ribs, then to the chest. And when her opponent can barely catch her breath, Maritza's up, giving her a fierce combination to the face and head.
她正在战斗的女人比她高，有更长的手臂。所以玛丽扎低头躲避，向身体刺拳，选择她落在哪里——肋骨，然后是胸部。当她的对手几乎喘不过气来时，玛丽扎站了起来，给她的脸和头一记激烈的组合拳。
There goes the uppercuts. There goes another one to the body.
上勾拳来了。又来了一个身体上的。
Ow.
噢。
Another one to the body, another one, another one.
又一个身体上的，又一个，又一个。
In the last 10 seconds, Manson gets in a good punch, straight to Maritza's face. Maritza stumbles back and then seems to go crazy. She throws nonstop combinations, and the crowd is screaming.
最后10秒，曼森打出了一记好拳，直击玛丽扎的脸。玛丽扎向后踉跄，然后似乎疯了。她扔出不间断的组合拳，人群在尖叫。
There, there goes the hook. See that? Whoa. That's it. 10 seconds. Bam. There you go. I threw it all.
那里，勾拳来了。看见了吗？哇。就是这样。10秒。砰。给你。我扔了一切。
Go, go. There you go. There you go. There you go. There you go. Throw it. I missed a lot, but I threw.
走，走。给你。给你。给你。给你。扔它。我错过了很多，但我扔了。
[BELL RINGING]
[铃声响起]
Can we just watch the last 10 seconds? That was so cool. Oh my god. You are so good, Maritza. I want to see you fight so badly.
我们可以只看最后10秒吗？那太酷了。天哪。你太棒了，玛丽扎。我太想看你打架了。
After the fight ends, we're laughing. We keep rewinding to watch Maritza's amazing finale.
比赛结束后，我们在笑。我们一直在倒带看玛丽扎令人惊叹的终曲。
I'm like, really? You got it good, right? Well, OK. All right, all right, all right, all right. OK, OK. Yeah, that was a grin. That was a good grin. That was a good grin.
我就像，真的？你做得很好，对吗？好吧，好的。好的，好的，好的，好的。好的，好的。是的，那是一个咧嘴笑。那是一个好咧嘴笑。那是一个好咧嘴笑。
We're both completely high and hysterical. Maritza's face is transformed. This is pure joy. And in a way it's terrible, because we both know she's quitting boxing.
我们两个都完全亢奋和歇斯底里。玛丽扎的脸变了。这是纯粹的快乐。从某种意义上说，这太可怕了，因为我们都知道她要退出拳击。
Maritza wants to go pro, but there doesn't seem to be any way she could make a living at boxing. She's only 106 pounds. They don't even have a name for her weight class. If she went pro, no one knows of any women who are good enough to match her.
玛丽扎想走职业，但似乎没有办法能让她通过拳击谋生。她只有106磅。他们甚至没有给她的体重级命名。如果她走职业，没人知道有什么女性好到足以匹配她。
As it is, there are only two amateur women at her level. In all her title matches, she's always been put up against these same two opponents over and over. And she's beat them every time. In 10 years, there may be enough women that Maritza would be able to make a career of it, but she's already in her 30s. She says she has to be realistic about the future.
实际上，在她的水平上只有两个业余女性。在她所有的冠军赛中，她总是被安排与这两个对手一次又一次地对抗。她每次都击败了她们。10年内，可能有足够的女性让玛丽扎能够从事这个职业，但她已经30多岁了。她说她必须对未来现实一点。
I get mixed feelings. When I go into the gym, I want to do it. But when I come away from the gym and I start looking at reality, it's like, I'm sad. It's like a sadness.
我有复杂的感觉。当我进入健身房，我想做。但当我离开健身房开始面对现实时，就像，我很伤心。这就像一种悲伤。
Nobody sees it on the outside. No one sees it. But on the inside, it's like it died. It's like, god, it could have been you. You should be in there, boxing.
没人从外面看到它。没人看到它。但在里面，就像它死了。就像，天哪，本来可能是你。你应该在那里面，打拳。
It's like she's in love with someone she knows she has to leave. So she circles around boxing, quits, comes back for one-night stands. Last year, Milton signed her up for the Metros tournament without telling her. On the night of the fight, he called her from ringside and told her they were holding up the match for her. Maritza got in her car and drove from Queens to Brooklyn while Milton lied to the judges about Maritza being stuck in traffic. She arrived, beat her opponent in three rounds flat, but was so disgusted with herself for fighting when she was trying to retire that she left without even collecting her trophy.
就像她爱上了一个她知道必须离开的人。所以她在拳击周围徘徊，退出，回来进行一夜情。去年，米尔顿在没告诉她的情况下给她报名参加了大都会锦标赛。比赛当晚，他从拳击场边打电话给她，说他们在为她推迟比赛。玛丽扎上了她的车，从皇后区开车到布鲁克林，而米尔顿对裁判撒谎说玛丽扎被困在交通中。她到了，在三回合内打败了她的对手，但因为她在试图退休时打架而对自己感到非常厌恶，以至于她没带走她的奖杯就走了。
But being back in the game felt too good. And after that win, she just couldn't bring herself to walk away. Despite her reservations, she went on to fight in the 1997 New York Gloves and, of course, won.
但回到比赛中感觉太好了。而在那次胜利之后，她只是无法让自己离开。尽管有顾虑，她还是继续参加了1997年的纽约金手套比赛，当然，赢了。
Come right here real quick. There you go. See the difference? Go.
马上过来。给你。看见不同了吗？走。
In February, just after Maritza misses the deadline for the 1998 Golden Gloves, I go to Milton's gym to see her fight. Even though, these days, Maritza isn't there much anymore, Milton has promised me that Maritza will spar with a new girl he's training. We wait and wait, and no Maritza. An hour passes.
二月，就在玛丽扎错过1998年金手套比赛报名截止日期后，我去米尔顿的健身房看她打架。尽管这些天玛丽扎已经不在那里了，米尔顿向我保证玛丽扎会和他在训练的一个新女孩进行陪练。我们等啊等啊，没玛丽扎。一个小时过去了。
When she finally shows, she looks worn out and tired. She's not dressed to box, and she says she's got the flu. She's not going to fight. Right away, everyone starts pushing her.
当她最终出现时，她看起来筋疲力尽。她没穿拳击装，她说她得了流感。她不打算打架。立刻，每个人都开始推她。
Well, let's just do a little.
好吧，让我们做一点吧。
Do you want to?
你想要吗？
Yeah.
是的。
But I got nothing with me.
但我什么都没带。
What do you need?
你需要什么？
Everything. I don't have nothing.
一切。我什么都没有。
She says she didn't bring her shoes. She doesn't have any of her gear. Milton points to some shoes lying in the corner, says they're her size. Suddenly, Maritza doesn't look so tired.
她说她没带她的鞋。她没有任何装备。米尔顿指着角落里放着的几双鞋，说它们是她的尺码。突然，玛丽扎看起来没那么累了。
But I got to tell you, I have no mouthpiece.
但我得告诉你，我没带牙套。
Then Maritza drops the pretense. We head down in the elevator to her car. Turns out, she's been carrying her gloves, her mouthpiece, her wraps, all of her equipment in her car for the past year, just in case.
然后玛丽扎放弃了假装。我们乘电梯去她的车。原来，过去一年她一直把她的手套、牙套、绷带，所有装备放在车里，以防万一。
I knew this was going to happen. That's why I don't want to come around here. That's why I don't want to come.
我知道这会发生。这就是我不想来这里的原因。这就是我不想来的原因。
You've got the biggest smile on your face. You look so happy right now.
你的脸上带着最大的微笑。你现在看起来太快乐了。
Because I love boxing, that's why. It's got me where I'm at today, OK, very happy and very balanced, I guess. We're around Second Avenue, Second Avenue, between Second and Third, and 13th Street. So here I am, with no voice, going in this room to go spar. Is that crazy? That's crazy?
因为我热爱拳击，这就是原因。它让我今天在这里，好吗，非常快乐和平衡，我猜。我们在第二大道，第二大道，在第二和第三街之间，第13街。所以我在，没有声音，走进这个房间去陪练。那疯狂吗？那疯狂吗？
She grabs her bag, and we race back to the gym. And as Maritza's getting dressed, I notice she wears tiny golden gloves on a chain around her neck. Milton stands ringside, pumped up, ready to see his favorite in action again.
她抓起她的包，我们赛车回到健身房。当玛丽扎正在穿衣服时，我注意到她脖子上带着一串细小的金手套项链。米尔顿站在场边，充满能量，准备再次看到他最爱的人行动。
This is Howard Kelso live, right here from Supreme Team Boxing.
这是霍华德·凯尔索现场直播，就在Supreme Team Boxing这里。
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
Box.
盒。
Relax your shoulders, Maritza. Relax your shoulders. Too tight. Ooh, good one.
放松你的肩膀，玛丽扎。放松你的肩膀。太紧了。噢，好的一拳。
Maritza's stiff at first, then she starts to relax. She's ducking down, dancing around the ring. And in the last 10 seconds of the fight, she has a surge of energy. She's punching hard, moving fast, throwing nonstop combinations.
玛丽扎起初很僵硬，然后她开始放松。她低头躲避，在拳击场上跳舞。在比赛的最后10秒，她能量暴涨。她出拳有力，移动快速，不停地扔出组合拳。
Come on, girl.
来吧，女孩。
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
Time.
时间。
And afterwards, she's pumped up with adrenaline, sweating, laughing with Milton and the guys in the gym. She says she'll be back to spar and train every week. And even though she's missed the deadline for this year's Golden Gloves, she swears she'll take the gloves next year. Stay tuned for 1999, she says. Stay tuned.
之后，她充满了肾上腺素，流着汗，和米尔顿以及健身房里的伙计们笑着。她说她每周都会回来陪练和训练。即使她错过了今年金手套比赛的截止日期，她发誓明年会拿到手套。明年见，她说。明年见。
But Maritza doesn't show at Milton's the next week or the week after. She breaks two appointments with me. She doesn't return my calls. And when I finally reach her, she's angry-- angry she fought again, scared she's getting sucked back in.
但玛丽扎下周或下下周没出现在米尔顿的健身房。她和我取消了两次约会。她没回我的电话。当我最终联系上她时，她很生气——生气她又打了架，害怕她被吸回去。
And how about the fact that you're still carrying around your gear?
而且你一直带着你的装备的事实怎么样？
Well, I guess I can't let go of boxing yet. Maybe it's my security blanket. It's like always knowing that it's always there, that I can always hit that bag. I get in front of the mirror at my house every day, just jab and come around, and do the moves.
好吧，我猜我还不能放弃拳击。也许它是我的安全毯。就像总是知道它总是在那里，我总能击中那个袋子。我每天在房子的镜子前，只是刺拳然后绕过来，做动作。
It's my connection to boxing. I carry this with me. I sleep with it. I have gloves in my car. I love it. It's me.
这是我和拳击的联系。我带着这个。我带着它睡觉。我的车里有手套。我爱它。这是我。
That story from Meema Spadola. Maritza has stopped boxing herself. She's aged out of it. These days, she teaches people to box.
那个故事来自米玛·斯帕多拉。玛丽扎自己停止了拳击。她年纪大了，离开了。这些天，她教别人拳击。
Our program was produced today by our production manager Stowe Nelson and our technical director Matt Tierney. Other people who helped put together today's show include Noor Gill, Lina Misitzis, Katherine Rae Mondo, Christopher Swetala, and Julie Whitaker. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Our managing editors are Sarah Abdurrahman and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由我们的生产经理斯托·尼尔森和我们的技术总监马特·蒂尔尼制作。帮助制作今天节目的其他人包括努尔·吉尔、莉娜·米西齐斯、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和朱莉·惠特克。我们的执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的管理编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼和黛安·吴。
Those guys that you heard at the beginning of the show, Jason Kirk and Spencer Hall, their essay about sports was originally published on the website Hazlitt. Their upcoming book is called The Sinful Seven-- Sci-fi Western Legends of the NCAA. Our website, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org.
你在节目开头听到的那些家伙，杰森·柯克和斯宾塞·霍尔，他们关于体育的文章最初发表在网站Hazlitt上。他们即将出版的书名为《罪恶七人组——NCAA的科幻西部传说》。我们的网站，你可以完全免费流式传输我们超过700集节目的档案，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. Every Friday at the end of the day, sends out an email to all of us, and it always says the same thing.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。每个周五结束时，他会发邮件给我们所有人，总是说同样的话。
Love you guys. I love you guys. Take tomorrow off.
爱你们，伙计们。我爱你们，伙计们。明天休息。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。